madame la Première ministre vous avez
présenté hier les premiers axes du plan
de réduction de gaz à effet de serre
afin de nous conformer à la feuille
européenne qui prévoit une baisse de 50%
des émissions d'ici à 2030 et la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050 le
respect de ce cadre européen dans le
droit fil des accords de Paris est un
pré requis pour faire face à l'urgence
écologique suivant les préconisations du
GIEC la France est engagée sur une
réduction à 270 millions de tonnes
équivalents CO2 d'ici 2030 soit un
doublement de la baisse de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre le chemin qu'il
reste à parcourir nécessite une
accélération collective et la
mobilisation de tous
parallèlement à l'atténuation les
efforts doivent également porter sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique
car s'adapter ce n'est en rien renoncé
s'adapter c'est anticiper les
conséquences du changement climatique
dont on sait qu'il touche davantage les
plus vulnérables Paris à 50 degrés nous
relèvent malheureusement pas de la
science-fiction et les conséquences
seront majeures sur ces habitants je
pense notamment à la question du
logement la rénovation thermique doit
désormais être pensée pour se protéger
des pics de chaleur qui rendront
certains appartements inhabitables alors
que le marché connaît une importante
tension les politiques d'adaptation
doivent veiller à ce que l'habitabilité
soit renforcée
face au phénomène météorologiques
extrême l'insécurité alimentaire
l'impact sur la biodiversité les
conséquences sur la santé l'adaptation
n'est pas une option et elle doit être
socialement juste pour que chacun y
adhère monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires vous avez annoncé le
lancement d'une large concertation pour
préparer le troisième plan national
d'adaptation changement climatique
pouvez-vous nous indiquer les actes de
travail que vous proposez pour prévenir
l'escalade des risques et nous préciser
comment le plan s'articulera avec le
fond vert je vous remercie